legally oh good girl there you go okay
hello hi it's been a while oh you got it
first and foremost the most important
thing on the agenda today is that it is
chica's birthday
so everyone please take a moment go in
the comments and wish her a very happy
birthday she is six years old today
and she is still so comfortable with me
picking her up you can see by her face
that is the most comfortable dog you've
ever seen a second
information thing probably the next most
important thing is yes i got a haircut
um
yeah i got a haircut it's purely out of
laziness
so now i have short hair again you're
very good girl
uh you may have noticed that videos have
been haphazard
at best um i've been number one writing
a ton but number two
in about a month i leave to film
something i'm playing the lead role in a
project that i can't tell you about yet
but
um i'm that's happening and uh
you're a very good girl you're a very
good girl okay you wanna go down
you don't have to good girl good girl
so yeah uh it's chica's birthday i got a
haircut i've been very busy
also new cloak drop today i've
officially ruined this with the amount
of dog hair that
i just put on it i'm uh i'm gonna go get
it i'm gonna go get a new um
shirt okay there we go that's better uh
if you want to see the rest of these go
to cloakbrand.com
uh you can check out the whole
collection i'm very proud of it but the
more important takeaway from this video
is that it is chica's birthday so please
be sure to wish her a very happy
birthday in the comments below
and i will try to make sure that she at
least looks at the comment section and
and also just the takeaway is that i am
fine
and i am always as i always have been
excited to make things
it's just that it just so happens that
everything that was
up in the air over the past year has
started
all coming down at once and i got to
make sure that i catch them all so
nothing
gets broken on the ground but i have
backlogged some videos
uh for my channel i have uh prepared
a lot of things for the future and if
everything goes according to plan and
everything goes
well you're gonna see a lot of really
cool stuff and i just can't wait for you
to see it
like i'm super excited that things are
finally starting up again
and gonna be finished off however
it means a wild sprint for me and i am
only one man and i know that i have
limitations as much as i wish i was
superman i am just one guy
and i only have so many hours in the day
and that's what i have to remember
so i need to use them as efficiently as
possible to make cool stuff for you guys
to see
thank you everybody so much for watching
oh by the way my my foot is my foot is
still broken
um but it's getting better the doctor
it's getting better the doctor said
uh that it's healing well it doesn't
need surgery you know i don't need a
good
rod put in or anything uh but it's gonna
be another month before it's
uh fully healed so still wearing the
boot but i can kind of hobble on it so
i'm good there
uh and that's it i'm gonna wrap this up
because this has been a very rambly vlog
but thank you everybody so much for
watching and thank you for your support
i do love the fact that when you know
delays like this happen in videos
that no one panics anymore no one no
one's immediately running around with
their
heads cut off screaming at the heavens
uh i i really appreciate
that people understand generally that
when i am not
hitting my video schedule it's because i
am busy with other things i love to make
i just do that's just who i am i love
making things
and my ambition overreaches my ability
at many times but i'm still going to
commit myself
to getting the best stuff that i can
make for you so thank you
more important takeaway obviously
chica's birthday so write her a happy
birthday message down below
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye